Oui, oui,
la politique de vengeance de l'état d'Israël sur les
les Palestiniens,
peuple opprimé, colonisé, réprimé, depuis des décennies,
provoque de plus en plus d'opposition et de révolte
partout dans le monde.
C'est l'expression d'une colère
à la fois contre la politique de néthania ou,
mais aussi
contre celle de des grandes puissances impérialistes
qui soutiennent inconditionnellement l'état d'Israël.
Oui, s'ils le voulaient,
les États-Unis pourraient faire pression sur néthania
ou pour stopper ce massacre.
Les États-Unis
contribuent au financement l'état d'Israël
à hauteur de 4.000.000.000 euh.
De dollars euh. Par an.
Le congrès, là, vient de euh,
voter 1 rallonge de 14 milliards.
Ils envoient euh, euh,
1 grande partie des armes qu'utilisent aujourd'hui euh.
L'armée israélienne.
Et puis les États-Unis ont envoyé sur place
2 porte-avions, ils ont envoyé également euh.
Des instructeurs euh.
Militaires et ils mettent à la disposition euh. D'Israël
leur euh. Satellite par exemple.
Mais même si les États-Unis
craignent que ce massacre mette le feu
à toute la région, et même s'il préférerait euh. Que euh,
l'armée israélienne agisse avec plus de modération,
bien, ils restent sur leur ligne de soutien à Israël
parce que c'est l'état qui reste dans la région,
leur soutien le plus fidèle et le plus fiable
pour les grandes puissances.
Le Moyen-Orient euh,
d'où provient 40% du pétrole consommé euh.
Dans le monde,
reste bien sûr 1 région cruciale,
le canal de Suez, et la clé euh. Du commerce global.
Et dans cette période euh.
De Guerre économique féroce
entre les États-Unis et la Chine.
Dans cette période où il y a la guerre
en Ukraine, et bien, il n'est pas question
pour les États-Unis de changer leur stratégie
au Moyen-Orient.
Alors les Palestiniens sont sacrifiés
sur l'hôtel de l'impérialisme.
Et cela dure depuis 75 ans.
Alors oui, le sort des Palestiniens
est 1 symbole de la domination
de l'impérialisme sur le monde,
1 symbole de l'arrogance de ces grandes puissances
qui disposent du globe
comme si c'était leur propriété privée
et qui traitent
les peuples, euh,
comme quantité négligeable.
Le sort des Palestiniens fait écho
souffrance des opprimés du monde entier.
Euh. Les morts de Gaza renvoient aux morts euh, du Soudan,
euh du Congo, euh de l'Afghanistan,
du Mali. Les réfugiés palestiniens
renvoient
aux 1.000.000 de femmes et d'hommes qui sont chassés
euh. De chez eux par les guerres,
par euh par la misère,
et qui se retrouvent eux aussi réfugiés à vie.
Alors l'émotion et la solidarité vis-à-vis euh,
des Palestiniens
doivent se transformer en conscience
que tous les opprimés
de cette terre partagent 1 sort et 1 combat commun,
celui de renverser l'impérialisme.
On ne peut qu'être
solidaire avec le combat des Palestiniens
pour imposer
leurs droits à 1 existence nationale à côté de celles
des Israéliens.
Mais
même les peuples qui l'ont conquise de haute lutte
restent dépendants économiquement
des pays riches.
Et combien de héros nationalistes
sont devenus des dictateurs infâmes ?
Et il ne faut pas en être surpris,
parce Que dans cet ordre capitaliste,
chercher à se faire 1 petite place nationale,
cela signifie
rester dans le piège de la domination
et de la dépendance.
que les opprimés du monde s'émancipent complètement,
il faudra, je le redis,
renverser l'impérialisme.
Et nous, qui sommes dans 1 de ces citadelles,
nous avons 1 rôle décisif à jouer,
construire 1 parti
visant au renversement du capitalisme
et à l'édification d'une société socialiste
dirigé par les travailleurs à l'échelle internationale,
1 parti qui
opposera à la politique de division de la bourgeoisie
le mot d'or d'unité de tous les
opprimés et les travailleurs
de la planète.